hello everyone I'm going to talk about
customer Victors in games or Hazard free
computation this is a joint work with
Christian naked Meyer and palaval
kumarada
so hazards in digital logic are spurious
electronic glitches or pulses that occur
at an output gate during an input
transition due to physical delays in
wire circuits so for example consider
the implementation of multiplexer on one
bit shown here
this output gate outputs the value of y
if x is set to 1 and if x is set to 0 it
outputs a value of C
so consider the evaluation of the
circuit at the input 0 1 1. at 0 1 1 x
is set to 0 so this red and gate
evaluates to zero whereas this black and
gate evaluates to one and so the overall
output evaluates to 1. now consider the
transition from this input to the input
1 1 so basically you flip the bit X
further suppose that this red and gate
has longer delays than this black and
gate
right so what happens temporarily is
this when you flip the input bit X to
one this red and gate continues to see
the old value which is zero and this uh
black and gate sees the new value which
is also zero why because X is equal to 1
now and so negation of X is zero right
so for a moment this output gets can
outputs the value 0 right and this is
known as 1 0 1 glitch right so you are
supposed to see one continuously but for
a moment you will see Zero and why are
hazards important in practice because if
you have a hazard free implementation
then you would you will be sure that no
glitches will occur regardless of the
physical delays in wire circuits
also hazards are major source of power
dissipation in in circuits and so they
are important in plsi design
in cyber security they are used for gate
level information flow tracking while in
distributed system Hazard free
implementation is solved when agents
with unsynchronized clock domains
perform parallel computation
they are also studied in logic uh
properly known as cliniologic
right so let's try to understand them
mathematically now so if we have a
function f on n Bits right and consider
a string Alpha on 0 u 1 to the N that
says n bit string over 0 1 and 2.
and with this string you can think of it
really as a partial input where the bits
which are set to 1 and 0 are defined
with stable bits whereas the undefined
bits can take any value between 0 and 1.
with this interpretation you can define
a sub cube with respect to this partial
input alpha or this is string Alpha this
is basically the set of all Boolean
strings which agrees with Alpha I
whenever Alpha I is not equal to U
right so basically what you do is you
take the alpha I and for you you can
split replace it with 0 or 1 and obtain
a new string right so for example if
your Alpha was U one zero Cube then the
sub cube of this string is given by the
set of these strings right so you can
see in the place of U and U you have
replaced with all possible values upon
and zeros right so you get four such
strings Boolean strings
right so this is what we understand by
sub cube of alpha once we have this
notion we can Define what is called as a
hazard free extension of the Boolean
function here and we denote it by F Bar
so its input is a string over 0 1 U to
the N so you will interpret this string
as a sub Cube and on this sub Cube if
the function f is constant then you
output that constant value in particular
if f is equal to 1 everywhere then you
output 1 if f is equal to 0 everywhere
on the sub Cube then you output 0 and if
neither of the case holds then you
output U okay so this is how the hazard
free extension is defined and for every
string on which Hazard free extension
evaluates to one is also known as one
certificate of the function or an
implicant of the function
similarly on every in on every string on
which uh Hazard pre-extension F Bar
evaluates to zero is known as zero
certificate or implicate of f
right so these are basically just a set
of literals and we also need a
definition of prime implicant a prime
implicant is just an implicant which is
minimal with respect to the set
inclusion that is any subset of this set
of literals is not an implicant of a
function
okay so let us now see how what do we
mean by a circuit to be Hazard free
and for this we need to extend the
Boolean logic to the cleaning logic
while incorporating the undefined bit
right so how do we extend the Boolean
Gates so let's look at and so zero and
undefined or unstable you really think
of it as an undefined or unstable fit so
here we know the function value so it
should output 0 1 and undefined we don't
know the function value it will depend
on this undefined bit so the function
value is again are different undefined
and undefined is under
similarly one or undefined is one zero
or undefined is under undefined or
undefined is undefined similarly
negation of quantifying is underground
right so now inductively on the
structure of the circuit you can
evaluate a circuit uh on a given a
string in 0 1 U to the N right and uh
when you can evaluate a circuit on such
a string then you say that c computes f
in a hazard freeway if on every string
the output of C agrees with the hazard
Creek extension
right
so really it's saying that if I input a
certificate Alpha is a say one
certificate or a zero certificate then
the circuit should output one or zero
right and conversely we say that c has a
hazard at Alpha if C of alpha is not
equal to I have F Bar of alpha that is
if Alpha is a one certificate that is f
power of alpha is one and C of Alpha Phi
values to zero and in such a case Alpha
is set to be one hazard similarly Alpha
is said to be a 0 Hazard if Alpha is a
zero certificate but the circuit
evaluates too undefined on this value
right so let's look at an example uh
multiplexer function over one bit and we
had seen this implementation before it
is X and Y or negation X and C right and
we had seen that it has this 1 0 1
Hazard right so in this mathematical
terms now it means the following so
consider the certificate to q11 this is
a one certificate because irrespective
of the value of x the function value
will be one right on this certificate
let's see how the circuit evaluates so X
is set to undefined and Y is set to 1 so
therefore this and gets evaluate to
undefined now access it to undefined
recognization of excellent defined and Z
is set to 1. so therefore this and could
also evaluates to undefined and in
particular then this implies that the
output kit also evaluates to one
different
so now there here is this one
certificate on which the circuit
evaluates to undefined and therefore it
is one Hazard right you see we took uh
get rid of this Hazard is by including
the term Y and C in the dnf
representation of this mux one
right
so in terms of Prior work as early as
Huffman had looked at Hazard free
circuits and he showed that every
bullion function does have a has
exercise circuit in particular the one
is the DNA with all minimal one
certificates
but it can be of exponential size
example majority all n by two side sets
are minimal ones by secretary right
later on Eichelberger gave an
exponential time algorithm to detect
hazards and suit that Hazard free DNA
must include all minimum wall
certificates so it's sort of tightened
with the Huffman pump
as an input
let's put this algorithm in perspective
with this power from Chandra and
markovsky which says that there exist
functions which have nearly as many as
uh mainly as many as possible Prime
implicants and implicits that is at
least three to the N over n and also
there exists dnf with K terms which have
as many as 3 to the K over 3 Prime
applicants right so the previous
algorithm necessarily an exponential
time algorithm
right recently uh the work of Eakin
Meyer kumara
regenerated interest in Hazard free
complexity in particular they proved
that for monotone functions have the two
complexity coincide that is the high
side free complexity is equal to the
monotone complexity and more importantly
they showed that Hazard free complexity
of f is lower bounded by the monotone
complexity of Hazard derivative of it
and this opens up new ways to probe
lower bounds or Hazard free complexity
by the monotone complexity
they also showed that detecting Hazard
written in P hard and gave a
construction for keep it Hazard result
that is circuits which are correct on
inputs in which there are at most K
undefined bits later on in a joint work
with covert we showed that the Brute
Force algorithm to detect hazards is
optimal assuming ACTH even in low type
circuits for dnfs we get a polytime
algorithm and it remains open to
characterize the complexity in depth 3
circuits
structural results among other things he
showed that Hazard fluid in Morgan
circuits must produce all prime
implicants and Prime implications
synchronically
also that minimal Hazard free circuit
for monotone functions are in fact
Monopoly so the negations are useless
for computing monotone functions in a
hazard three-way
we also showed that every Boolean
function on N bit has a hazard free
Circuit of size or other two to the N
Over N so nearly matching the lupunox
upper bound
right so in essence what we have is
there is only one way to prove lower
bound or Hazard free complexity of air
and that is why the monotone complexity
has a derivative of it so let us look at
what is this Hazard derivative of x so
of a Boolean function f over n Bits the
hazard derivative is another Boolean
function over 200 bits where the first
part of the input is denoted by X and
the second part of n Bits between
denoted by one and given X and Y you
construct the string X Plus U dot y over
0 1 U which is which is basically the
bitwise operation so it is x 1 plus u
dot y 1 then x 2 plus c u dot Y2 and so
on and so forth and essentially what is
it is saying is that if y1 is equal to
if y i is equal to 0 then that bit
should be equal to x i and if y i is
equal to 1 then that bit should be equal
to U right so when you get this string
with this string when you integrate it
as a sub queue now you look over the sub
Cube whether f is constant or not if f
is not constant of the sub Cube then you
are equal to 1 and if it is equal to a
constant function then you output 0
right so this is the hazard derivative
of a Boolean function and it can matter
at also that when you consider this as a
derivative with respect to the second
set of variables that is fix the first
set of variables 2 and input X and
within the second set of variables y
this Hazard derivative is a multiple
function and more importantly they
showed that the hazard very complexity
of f is lower bounded by the monotone
complexity of the hazard derivative at
any input X so you can choose the input
X of your own liking right and this is a
way to prove uh lower bound on
hazard-free complexity so the question
is can we use Hazard derivatives to
prove optimal lower bounds in the course
of this work we will show that the
answer to this question is let us look
at an example
so this is the multiplexer function so
multiplexer on N bit is has an address
bits and these n address bits gives an
address in the next 2 to the end bits so
it is defined on total Over N plus 2 to
the n Bits and then you output that bit
in the X right so you treat the first n
Bits as a number and then you output
that bit in x that is the multiplexer
function multiplexer function over one
bit
no multiplication function over one bit
can be implemented by this Hazard free
optimal formula we will see later that
this is indeed an optimal formula
and it is uh it is it is similar to the
one that we saw earlier but this has
five leaves whereas the earlier one had
six legs
and there is a well-known recurrence
relation for multiplexer in terms of uh
multiplexer on one bit and multiplexer
on N minus one so you can you can
Multiplex on the first bit S1 and
depending on its value you can output
the other function which is a
multiplexer on here minus 1 or S1 is
equal to one which is also another
multiplexer on N minus one bit right so
we're using this recurrence you can
unfold this formula further to n levels
and you can show that this is in fact a
hazard free formula Computing
multiplexer function and the size of
this formula based on frequency is at
most 2 times 3 to the N minus 1. right
so can we prove that this is the optimal
uh size or can we improve the size upper
Norm so let us look at the hazard
derivative method that we know uh what
sort of lower bound it can prove right
so we claimed that the hazard derivative
of the multiplexer function with respect
to any input s comma X is at most n
times 2 to the n
so let's look at a particular input 0
comma zero and at this place this has a
derivative is a Boolean function which
looks like this so you consider the
input 0 plus u dot Y which is basically
saying that if y i is equal to 0 then
you keep it 0 if y i is equal to 1 then
you will get a few consider this a
string and when you consider this a
string this is a true to the N length
string and when you restrict it to the
positions given by the sub Cube 0 plus u
dot T right then this string is a not
all zero string then you output one and
if it is then you output 0 right so so
just to reiterate uh you consider this
string and this should not be equal to
all zeros on the positions given by the
sub Cube 0 plus u dot T and this is the
sub cube of all Boolean strings which
are less than equal to T in the Boolean
partial order
okay
and if it is not or not if it is equal
to all zero then you output 0 right so
really to implement this what you need
to see is that uh right there is a u in
one of the positions and that you will
be there if the corresponding bit in the
Y is one right so you really need to
check if there is a bit in Y which is
one and if such then this bit should be
covered by the sub Cube position right
and first of all which means that you
know this index B should be less than
equal to P that means wherever b i is 1
a I must also be equal to one and this
is the implementation a monotone
implementation of the hazard derivative
of multiplexer function at zero zero
clearly you can see the bound that is it
is n plus 1 times 2 to the n
so from this we observe that Hazard
derivative can only prove a lower bound
of n times 2 to the n on the formula
size right whereas we had seen that the
upper bound is 2 times 3 to the N minus
1. so what is really the truth here
right and we will so in fact that the
upper bound is tied so by improving the
lower bound we will in fact so that the
hazard free formula complexity of
multiplexer is at least 2 times 3 to the
N minus 1 to show this we will intro
introduce a hazard free version of
Kashmir Victorian game for the function
act in this game Alice gets a one
certificate Alpha and Bob gets a zero
certificate beta and their goal is to
determine an index I in N such that
Alpha I is not equal to Beta I and at
the same time Alpha I and beta I are not
equal to U that is Alpha and beta take
values in 0 and 1. right so and then we
later saw that the cost of this of a
protocol solving this game so optimal
communication cost of a protocol solving
this game is equal to Optimal depth of a
hazard free formula Computing here
similarly optimal size of a protocol
solving this game is equal to Optimal
size of a hazard Computing net
so the optimal size that we screw here 2
times 3 to the N minus 1 and this is
given by this unfold in this recursive
formula as you see here that to get rid
of one of the index you need uh three uh
depth three and as you unroll n times
the depth will become three here
so really the optimal size protocol the
communication cost is 3M or the depth of
that formula is three so then one can
ask to optimize in terms of
communication cost and again so that in
fact there is a depth uh of uh there is
a two two n plus one depth Hazard free
formula for multiplexer that you can
obtain by giving a protocol of cost at
most two n plus 1 and the lower bound is
log three times n that follows from the
size here so there is still a gap here
uh similarly for a hazard free formula
with alternation depth at most two we
saw that the communication cost has to
be equal to 2 N Plus 2. we further
extend the asset free game uh to
characterized limited Hazard greens
which can lead towards General lower
bound
so now let's have a preview of a quick
overview of the lower bound result and
the lower bound says that the US has a
free formula size of the multiplexer is
at least two times three to the N minus
1. for this purpose we would need an
auxiliary function we call it a sub Cube
intersection function so this function
takes two sub cubes as input and is
equal to one if the two sub cubes
intersect and is equal to zero otherwise
right and clearly the two strings you
can interpret as sub Cube and that is
what it does it looks so that it is an
indicator function of whether the two
sub cubes in the intersect or not and
the Insight is that the hardness of
solving customer Victorian game for
multiplexer hazard precaution
multiplication game for multiplexer is
captured by this sub Cube intersection
problem right so we can show that
another subjective intersection problem
reduces to the hazard precautionary for
multiplexer with zero cost
so here suppose Alice gets Alpha a sub
Cube Alpha and Bob gets another sub Cube
data all right so then Alice constructs
Alpha prime or 2 to the N length string
over U and one and ones are only at the
positions that are given by sub Cube
Alpha similarly Bob constructs beta
Prime over 0 and U it is also a 2 to the
N length string and zeros are only add
to positions that are given by sub Cube
beta now clearly alpha alpha Prime
together forms a minimal one certificate
for multiplexer similarly beta beta
Prime forms a minimal zero certificate
for multiplexer so the two parties can
now solve customer return over the
multiplexer alpha alpha Prime and beta
for multiplexer over alpha alpha Prime
and beta beta Prime and the answer to
this again will help them reduce whether
the two sub cubes intersect or not how
so one can observe that if the sub
queues does intersect that is a q of
alpha answer Q beta and I have a
non-trivial intersection then the alpha
and beta has to be consistent and that
means the difference has to be found in
the data variables that is in Alpha
Prime and beta Prime and if the sub
cubes are destroying that means they
have to contradict uh on a single
variable in Alpha and beta and so the
answer lies in the selector variables
that is Alpha and data so from the
answer to the crash multiplication game
for multiplexer they will be able to
reduce the answer to the sub Cube
intersection problem without any
communication
so this shows that the size of the
protocol solving crash multiplication
game for multiplexer is at least the
size for protocol for subcubator section
and it is well known that the size of a
protocol is at least two times the rank
of the communication Matrix minus one so
here in essence we have to show that the
rank of the communication Matrix for the
sub Cube intersection function is full
that is it is equal to 3 to the N which
is indeed what we saw and it can be
easily shown by induction on N so for n
equals 1 here is the Matrix the
communication Matrix and it is easily
seen to be of blank 3 and for uh
arbitrary and one can show that the
communication Matrix is basically a
Chronicle product of this Matrix times n
and since rank is multiplicative with
respect to Chronicle product we get that
the rank of the communication Matrix of
the sub Cube intersection problem is 3
to the N from where you get that the
size of the protocol is at least two
times three to the N minus 1 and in
particular size of the protocol solving
Hazard free cash multiplication game for
multiplexer is at least two times three
to the N minus 1.
so let me now wrap up with open problems
one can ask uh you know KRW conjecture
in the hazard free setting is it true
uh similarly for the hazard free
formulas uh we have an upper bound of 2
times 3 to the N minus 1 that follows
from the construction of multiplexer you
just plug in the truth table affair
while the lower bound is 2 to the N over
log n right from the general formula so
there is a reasonable Gap here to be
closed what is the truth value
similarly for the depth Bound for
multiplexer we know that the N bit
multiplexer has a has actually formula
of size of depth that goes to n plus one
and this increase in size is only 1 8
additive increase so it's not much
whereas the lower bound from the size
policy is 1.58 times n plus one so what
is the truth value here
similarly one can try to prove lower
bounds and limited has accurate settings
progressing towards smooth General
circuits similarly one can also ask
minimum circuit size problem for in the
hazard free setting uh in particular we
know that you know minimizing DNS is
hard SNP complete whereas minimizing
Hazard fluid units is polynomial time
solvable
so there are something to be explored
here thank you for listening to me and
if you have any questions or comments
please feel free to write to us
thank you